Hello everyone. So in this video we are going to understand about the chemical law
of equivalence. Here we will just understand the basic of it,
okay? The overall chemical law of equivalence will be taught
to you in the redox chapter or in the stichometric
part two or what we call it mole concept part two,
okay? But here we are going to just cover the basic part of
chemical Law of Equivalence. What chemical law of equivalence is?
Basically, for that you must have an idea of equivalence first.
If not, then go and watch the video where I have taught you the equivalence,
okay? Because without equivalence, you will not be able to understand the chemical
law of equivalence. So let's understand what
basically chemical law of equivalence is state, okay?
So what basically equivalence law of equivalence
is. So law state that one equivalent
of an element combines with one
equivalent of the other. So if there is a reaction,
okay, if there is any reaction and that need not to be
balanced actually, this is the advantage of law of Equivalence that you don't
need a balanced reaction to apply the law of equivalence.
Law of Equivalence can be applied to unbalanced reactions
also. It can be applied to unbalanced reactions
also. So talking about the chemical law of
equivalence, okay, talking about the chemical law of equivalence, the law
state that one equivalent of element combines
with the one equivalent of the other. Okay? So one equivalent
of the element combines with the one equivalent of the other, okay?
So here, if there are some equivalent, okay,
then we can assume that whatever the equivalent of this compound is
consumed, same amount of equivalent will be consumed for B,
okay? And similarly same equivalent of C
will be formed and same equivalent of D will be formed. This is what
the statement of first says that whatever the equivalent of one
is consumed, other also is consumed in the same ratio. Other also is
consumed in the same ratio. Okay? So this is what the statement says.
This is what the statement says that the law state that one
equivalent of the element combines with the one equivalent of the other. So easily
we can say that whatever the equivalent of A is there, it will be equal
to the equivalent of B and it will be equivalent equal to the equivalent of
C, it will be equal to the equivalent of D, okay?
Similarly, here there is another statement.
These two statements can be combinedly read, okay? So in a
chemical reaction equivalent or mill equivalent
of a reactant react in an equal amount to give the
same number of equivalent or the mill equivalent of the product
separately. So this is the simple statement here. This A and B are
basically consumed amount, okay? Here A and B are basically the
consumed amount. So these are the consumed amount while
this C and D are formed amount, okay? While this
C and d are the formed amount, okay? This C and D
are actually the formed amount, okay? So these are the formed amount
of the substance while this is the consumed amount of the substance. But they will
be equal. But they will be equal. You don't need
a balanced reaction. Remember that. I'm saying it again.
The biggest advantage of chemical law of equivalence
that it can be applied. It can be applied I'm writing here as a note
point to this point, okay? That law of equivalence
can be applied to unbalanced chemical reaction. And that is the
biggest advantage why we use law of equivalence, okay? So we can
say here that law of equivalence we
can say here that law of equivalence law of
equivalence is applicable
is applicable even to
those reaction even to those reaction
which are even to those reaction which are not
balanced. Which are not balanced, okay? So this is
the biggest advantage and generally applied to
those reactions which are of redox nature, okay?
Because balancing of redox is quite tough of so generally without
balancing, we apply the law of equivalence to get the final product amount
or the reactant consumed amount. Okay? So this is the method and
this is what we call it chemical law of equivalence.
Okay? So I hope that this is clear to you.